tous
le pense yves américaine contre la
consommation de drogue 8 milliards de
dollars pour lutter contre le fléau
reportage de jacques à bouchard à
washington pour le contrôle des
assurances victoire c'est suez qui gagne
et jean-marc verne qui s'incline une
affaire qui avait fait frémir la bourse
de paris
élections en afrique du sud est un
minimum puisque trois sud africains sur
quatre ne votent pas tous ceux qui ont
la peau noire
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux les
américains qui font rire c'est à
deauville pour le festival du film
une bonne surprise la comédie quand
harry rencontre sally
bonsoir ça y est c'est fait ils sont
rentrés 13 millions d'écoliers et de
lycéens sont retournés à leurs chères
études
aujourd'hui résumé du climat les parents
d'élèves sont inquiets les enseignants
s'interrogent alors qu'en pensent les
lycéens et bien pour le savoir-faire
nice réenquêter au lycée de montgeron
il s'est rendu compte que les lycéens
n'avaient finalement pas trop d'état
d'âme ils le savent
pour réussir la compétition est dur il
faut se battre
8h15 pour les deux mille trois cent
quarante cinq élèves du lycée de
montgeron
c'est la rentrée 70 classes avec des
effectifs de 35 à 37 élèves ils sont
nombreux ils le savent et pour eux cela
veut dire se battre c'est pas parce
qu'ils sont de voir aux copains parce
que sinon il a copié et puis il avoir
une meilleure note vous enfin installer
des salles et comportements sont
sournois hypocrite c'est comme ça 8h45
cette fois ci on reprend vraiment le
colis
ce retour aux bonnes vieilles habitudes
va très vite dissiper les appréhensions
al'inverse de leurs professeurs ou même
de leurs parents les lycéens n'ont pas
d'état d'âme c'est chacun peu fou
personne va aider personne n'ose pas on
n'est pas pour laisser les honneurs
elle est parfois des périodes les autres
on est là pour réussir ça motive
énormément ça ça permet permet de défier
d'attendre dix qu'il allait au delà de
ses limites
c'est toujours très utile ce que ça peut
ça peut faire que j'ai dû bien une
vision très pragmatique un peu trop
peut-être
aux yeux de certains enseignants je nie
pas en tant qu'enseignant comme valeur
sûre le rendement bondir je sais pas
quels sous les mots à la mode déplétés
connaître mieux que moi le gagnant
non ça c'est pas c'est pas mon style je
crois pas que ce soit partagé par
beaucoup de profs
question de génération ou d'état
d'esprit en tout cas pour ces jeunes le
lycée c'est vraiment du sérieux
aujourd'hui on ne plaisante plus avec
les études la peur du chômage
il est sans doute pour quelque chose la
drogue
on en parle beaucoup dans le monde
entier la semaine dernière c'étaient les
producteurs colombiens qui était en
accusation cette fois ce sont les
consommateurs américains le président
bush annonce cette nuit le déblocage de
8 milliards de dollars pour une
gigantesque campagne de prévention
contre la drogue
il faut dire qu'on estime à 10 millions
le nombre d'intoxiquer aux états unis et
à trois fois plus le nombre de ceux qui
touchent de temps en temps à la drogue
alors voici le terrible reportage
constat de notre envoyé spécial à
washington jacquat bouchard
la 300 troisième victime de l'année à
washington dans la vague de folie
meurtrière dus à la drogue
ronald johnson 17 ans tué par un
camarade d'école entre dealers c'est à
celui qui tire le premier
pour le contrôle d'une rue ou d'un
quartier victimes meurtries ont
d'ailleurs le même profil ils sont
jeunes noirs aux et généralement
chômeurs
la brigade des stupéfiants est à tour de
bras multiplie les saisies ces sommes
sont débordés si crime sur dix sont
liées au trafic de drogue dans la
capitale fédérale
emmené au commissariat les petits
revendeurs connaissent le tarif deux ans
à passer sous les verrous mais avec les
tribunaux engorgés les prisons
surpeuplées
ils peuvent peut-être dehors dans les
six mois et la rendre commence face à
une demande très soutenue
la consommation a grimpé de 30% pour les
drogués se pique qui fument
régulièrement cette bataille là est déjà
perdu gros nous alors que nous gagnons
l'autre bataille celle des toxicomanes
occasionnels se procurer de la drogue
est un jeu d'enfant à washington où l'on
recense plus de 200 points de vente au
point des rues ou dans les parcs publics
le produit roi depuis cinq ans c'est la
cocaïne sud-américaine absorbée par voie
nasale et puis le tract se présente
comme du sucre en morceaux c'est un
dérivé puissant et bon marché de la
cocaïne à 30 cents la dose qui fait des
ravages parmi les jeunes y le plus
audi seat général le plus grand hôpital
de washington
l'alerté rouge est déclenchée tous les
vendredis soirs en cinq ans le nombre
d'urgences liés aux drogues dures
pendant les week-ends si x 10 les décès
par overdose en triple un fléau qui
oblige le très controversé maire de
washington marion de bari à revêtir un
gilet pare balles lorsqu'il entreprend
une tournée dans les quartiers sud de la
ville car à washington l'hécatombe
continue et pourrait approcher les 500
tués en 89 200 de plus qu'en 88 pourtant
une année record
j'ajoute qu'il y aura une conférence
internationale sur la drogue en avril 90
elle aura lieu à londres elle portera
sur la consommation et le trafic de la
drogue
pas de retour des grands chantiers
navals à la ciotat
la société américaine l'ex marc avait
fait une proposition dans ce sens c'est
à dire la réouverture d'un grand
chantier et elle avait déposé une
plainte contre la solution proposée peu
de temps avant par bernard tapie
mais l'ex marc vient d'être déboutée par
le tribunal de paris alors qu'en
pense-t-on dans le port de la
méditerranée en quête à la ciotat
patrice blais sylvie jouve il n'aura pas
fallu plus de cinq minutes au tribunal
de commerce pour rejeter l'offre de
l'armateur américain l'ex marc pour la
reprise des chantiers navals de la
ciotat
on a perdu une bataille on n'a pas perdu
la guerre donc vous allez continuez à
vous battre
on ne s'arrêtera pas on ne s'arrêtera
pas on peut pas enterrer 2000 emplois en
france dans une ville qui à 4500
chômeurs à la ciotat
la cgt se montre très déçu elle
soutenait le plan ambitieux farfelues
pour certains de l'américain qui
prévoyait de relancer la construction de
superpétroliers en france il faut nommer
gociations très rapide dans la réunion
d'une réunion quadripartite entre le
gouvernement le groupe tapie de lexmark
et la cgt avec le conseil général
propriétaire du domaine maritime pour
trouver une solution et permettre le
redémarrage pâti de la décision du
tribunal
elle neutralise ce soir le grand
vainqueur ces deux projets conduits par
bernard tapie est soutenu par le
gouvernement et le maire de la ciotat un
projet de diversification du site autour
de quatre pôles bateaux de plaisance
tourisme immobilier et industrie mais
l'ex maire ne s'avoue pas vaincu et
entend toujours développé son chantier
sur une partie du site de la ciotat avec
le soutien du conseil général
le feuilleton des chantiers navals n'est
peut-être pas terminée coup de tonnerre
dans le monde des travaux publics
francis bouygues passe la main l'homme
qui a introduit le béton à la télévision
l'homme qui a racheté tf1 a décidé de
laisser son fils martin lui succéder une
succession qui était d'ailleurs prévue
depuis quelque temps déjà
jean-pierre motivé mais qu'elle est
votée il te souhaite une bonne retraite
la remise annuelle des médailles de
l'ordre du minho rend aujourd'hui c'est
le fondateur de l'ordre lui même 67 ans
celui dont on dit hâtivement peut-être
qu'il est le numéro un mondial du
bâtiment qui cède à son fils martin 36
ans un fauteuil de pdg pesant 50 9
milliards de francs au siège
grandiloquent du groupe à saint quentin
en yvelines
francis bouygues conservera dit il un
rôle d'inspirateur parti de rien voici
trente ans
le bâtisseur du parc des princes de
l'arche de la défense de l'université de
ryad et des maisons de masson a réussi
semble-t-il sa succession attaqué en
bourse
voici un an par bernard tapie robert
maxwell c'est à dire par ses propres
alliés dans le vieux lyon aura réussi
semble-t-il à verrouiller son capital
bref à bétonner son entreprise contre
les attaques extérieures et enfin
économie toujours avec les pilotes du
les pilotes pardon d'une grande bataille
est là et fait frissonner tous les
boursiers de la place de paris nous en
avions largement parlé c'est la sphère
suez victoire alors je résume le groupe
suez avait lancé une opa pour prendre le
contrôle des assurances victoire mais le
patron de la compagnie industrielle qui
jusque là contrôlé victoire ce patron
donc jean-marc verne s'y opposer
formellement alors deviner ce qu'il en
advint et bien les deux groupes se sont
finalement mis d'accord mais c'est tout
de même 16 qui triomphe
claire chazal ils ont posé les armes la
bataille pour le contrôle de victoire le
second assureur français a pris fin
aujourd'hui
l'attaquant renault de l'ingénieur
patron du groupe suez l'a emporté mais
il paiera le prix fort
le président de victoires jean-marc
verne lui cette ces titres mais ils
l'obligent à surenchérir suez doit
porter de 13000 à 14 1800 francs le prix
de l'opéra l'opération ne lui coûtera
pas moins de 27 milliards de francs du
jamais vu
à la bourse de paris jean-marc verne lui
en poche une confortable plus-value près
de 6 milliards et demi de francs
c'est quand même une grande satisfaction
pour moi d'avoir obtenu de la compagnie
financière que le prix de 13 mille
francs tu es pu être portée à quatorze
1800 francs c'est à dire une
augmentation d'un peu plus de 13%
il en coûtera 3 milliards 3 de plus à la
compagnie financière de suez si tous les
titres viennent à l'opéra et je crois
que je suis allé au maximum de ce que
suez était prêt à payer
jean-marc verne c'est certes une belle
opération financière mais il perd le
pouvoir chez victoire un pouvoir qui
l'avait pourtant cherché à conserver par
tous les moyens ces derniers jours un an
après le rachat spectaculaire de la
générale de belgique suez deviendra
officiellement le 25 septembre prochain
date de
clôture de lober à l'un des grands de la
banque de l'industrie et de l'assurance
en europe
l'élection demain en afrique du sud où
il ne faut pas en attendre de grands
changements car comme toujours trois sud
africains sur quatre n'ont pas le droit
de voter
simplement parce qu'ils ont la peau
noire à noter tout de même cette
déclaration du premier ministre par
intérim monsieur de clerck
il affirme que l'apartheid doit
disparaître quoi qu'il en soit ce
problème de l'apartheid est toujours au
centre de la vie politique de l'afrique
du sud
exemple à carleton une petite ville de
l'afrique du sud profonde où se sont
rendus nos envoyés spéciaux martin
laroche joubert et alain c'est la
nostalgie du passé
leanne on le conseil municipal de
carleton ville décide de poser dans ses
parcs et jardins des panneaux blancs
seulement la cour suprême vient
d'annuler cette décision
le pouvoir le maire mais méfiance oblige
il enregistre cette news une cassette
c'est décidé il fera une histoire
jusqu'à ce jour unique en afrique du sud
car d'autres villes petite cité perdue
dans des champs de mines d'or après la
décision du conseil les noirs décident
de boycotter les magasins tenus par les
blancs le chiffre d'affaires s'écroule
oui nous avons eu un boycott qui a été
très dure où nous avons perdu beaucoup
d'argent
qu'est-ce que lina quelques-uns quelques
noirs qui sont revenus les deux derniers
mois mais c'est bien vrai boycott il a
duré au moins six mois
celle qui a porté l affaire devant la
cour suprême
la présidente de la chambre des
commerces question d'argent mais aussi
question de coeur rythmique j'ai tiré un
mec très humble abord je suis chrétienne
et et laissez moi vous dire que la
dignité humaine compte davantage que
l'argent même s'il est importante
tout ceci est bon pour les blancs est
aussi une star dont les noirs ce clip
résultat les panneaux blancs seulement
ont été enlevés une nuits de la semaine
dernière les noirs après un an
d'exclusion peuvent enfin s'asseoir dans
le pré on a vu que les panneaux étaient
enlevés on s'est assis mais on ne sait
pas si on a vraiment droit du coffre
vous savez on a aucun endroit ici pour
se reposer il ya tellement de monde dans
les rues
on ne sait pas où manger à guînes alors
ici oui c'est bien on est content mais
les plus heureux ici ce sont les
candidats du parti national qui compte
bien demain récupérer des voix
je pense que dans cette affaire les
électeurs qui sont contre ce que l'on
appelle le petit appart led vont voter
pour le parti national au pouvoir se
réjouit donc de se camoufler a figé par
la cour suprême à son principal
adversaire le parti conservateur dans
cette affaire il soutient a directement
les noirs en appuyant les revendications
de certains blancs toute l'ambiguïté et
la difficulté d'un programme des
filières pour la dernière fois avant les
élections par le prochain président sauf
imprévu surprenant frederik de klerk
réunion un peu morne où hier soir malgré
les prières et les chants pour le parti
national c'est la certitude le nombre de
sièges qu'il pourrait perdre demain au
profit de l'extrême droite
frederik de klerk paraît tout de même
optimiste en pologne monsieur mazowiecki
continue ses tractations pour former son
gouvernement
une discussion difficile notamment avec
les communistes pendant ce temps là les
cheveux les a effectué une visite de
quatre jours en allemagne fédérale à
düsseldorf philippe rochot l'a suivi
aujourd'hui très peu de sympathisants
mais plus de 150 journalistes à
l'aéroport de düsseldorf pour accueillir
un homme aussi populaire en allemagne
fédérale que gorbatchev lui-même walesa
à la sympathie de 85 % des allemands de
l'ouest
invité par la puissante centrale
syndicale dgb il vient chercher
d'urgence l'aide économique dont la
pologne a besoin pour la réussite des
réformes
walesa a obtenu une liste de 15 projets
d'investissement pour la région de
gdansk
la pologne doit déjà 200 milliards de
francs à l'allemagne mais vanessa on
veut encore 50 de plus la chance pour
lui c'est l'europe
il parle d'une europe idyllique où tout
le monde serait libre et où la pologne
serait un pays aussi prospère que
l'allemagne fédérale
tout au long de ses premiers entretiens
walesa a insisté sur la nécessité de
privatiser l'économie polonaise
les banques allemandes at il dit doivent
s'installer en pologne la population a
cumulé plus de 5 milliards de dollars
dans ses bas de laine et il faut les
faire fructifier
l'autre information internationale
maintenant est d'abord on reste en
allemagne mais en allemagne de l'est
cette fois manifestation à l'oeil psych
de ceux qui veulent t migrer en
allemagne de l'ouest de l'autre côté du
rideau de fer
roland sicard
de la filière hongroise aux
manifestations de rue le mouvement de
contestation s'amplifie en allemagne de
l'est
trois cents personnes hier dans les rues
de leipzig et des slogans comme liberté
de voyage plutôt que fils de masse pour
un état ouvert avec des citoyens libres
ou encore nous voulons partie
intervention de policiers en civil
vendront fisc et résultat plusieurs
arrestations et le gouvernement
est-allemand parle de fermeté
l'azerbaïdjan grève générale depuis hier
un mouvement qui touche les principales
villes de la région et qui serait suivie
à plus de 80% selon ses organisateurs
objectif des grévistes le retour du haut
karabagh où les arméniens sont
majoritaires sous la tutelle de
l'azerbaïjan en janvier dernier moscou
avait installé une administration
provisoire sur le territoire pour tenter
de mettre fin aux émeutes
deux morts sept blessés c'est le bilan
de l'explosion d'une voiture piégée dans
un quartier chrétien de béroul ce matin
alors que les beyrouthins profité d'une
accalmie dans les bombardements pour
aller faire leurs courses
une catastrophe beaucoup plus grave a
été évité de justesse un détonateur et
de missiles antichars n'ont pas explosé
le dernier attentat à la voiture piégée
en zones chrétiennes en mars dernier
avait fait 15 morts et de 110 blessés
à propos des migrations encore cette
affaire en france cette fois de romain
en voyage dans notre pays ont demandé
l'asile politique il était arrivé en
juin clandestinement ils se sont fait
prendre dans un train car il voyageait
sans billet pour maintenant c'est la
tente dans l' angoisse car s'ils sont
renvoyés dans leur pays la roumanie ils
iront directement en prison le régime de
ceaucescu n'est pas à un internement
près en quête d' agnès poirier
la fin d'un long périple il ya deux mois
florin son ami ont tous quitté leur
famille et leur pays la roumanie après
plusieurs semaines dans les camps de
réfugiés hongrois
ils traversent clandestinement
l'autriche et l'allemagne de l'ouest
à peine arrivée sur le sol français ils
sont interpellés et conduits menottes
aux poignets en cellule puis menacé
d'expulsion
mais leur rêve est intacte ils veulent
vivre ici en france nous avons choisi la
france parce que nous parlons la langue
française
et nous estimons que nous avons une
chance de nous intégrer ici nous sommes
des tirs et de travail et de commencer
une vie nouvelle
sans mensonges et 130 et aussi de vivre
digne et libre comme on doit vivre comme
ça qu'on doit à l'ordre à deux lignes
les deux jeunes roumains ont demandé
l'asile politique en france et l'offre à
l'office de protection des réfugiés à
accepter les recevoir en urgence demain
matin à paris mais si on le refuse le
statut de réfugié politique
le préfet l'a annoncé ils devront
quitter la france pour le pays de leur
choix
une chose est sûre florin et son ami ne
retourneront pas en roumanie
il risque là bas cinq ans de prison pour
propagande anti socialiste
nous n'avons jamais c'est pour un tel
régime de dictature communiste régime
inhumaines de la famille laroche est ce
qu un régime qui détruit dans le même
temps le passé le présent et le futur
dampierre laban biologique de notre
peuple
quelques semaines encore ils seront
fixés mais ils pensent à leurs amis ceux
qui sont restés là bas ils sont nombreux
ceux qui veulent fuir la dictature
roumaine
chaque jour nous ont ils dit trois cents
personnes quittent clandestinement la
roumanie cinq personnes interpellées à
paris trois italiennes et deux italiens
du matériel et une arme ont été
découverts à leur domicile et aussi ça
le domicile des tracts qui
revendiquaient des attentats en italie
il pourrait s'agir des membres des
brigades rouges en train de se
reconstituer
scandale à carcassonne dans un centre
pour handicapés en exploiter les malades
ont les ai travaillé pour rien ou
presque
sans compter que dans la caisse du
centre il y a maintenant un trou de 20
millions de francs louis carzou enquête
comptabilité ni fiable ni loyale
transfert au culte de personnel jeunes
handicapés utilisé d'une manière qui
relève de l'exploitation pure et simple
le rapport de l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales mais pas tendre avec
l'association de placement et des aides
aux jeunes handicapés de l'aude avec
plus de 40 unités de travail comme cette
menuiserie et près de 600 personnes
employées la ph j -h de l'aude
représente une des premières france
d'économie de carcassonne malgré de
nombreux avertissements de l'inspection
du travail et des infos aujourd'hui le
bilan de l'association accuse un déficit
de 20 millions de francs quant à la
société anonyme chargée de
commercialiser les productions de la ph
j -h son passif s'élève à 3 millions de
francs
une situation qui ne surprend pas
monsieur sylvestre procureur de la
république de carcassonne affaire avait
déjà attiré l'attention de mon parquet à
l'occasion de conflits de travail les
imputations des détournements qui
opposait
certains dirigeants de centre à la
direction de la pj h
de fait l'association ne possédait aucun
commissaire aux comptes le rapport par
le même de tromperie sur l'identité la
rémunération et l'affectation des agents
certains handicapés aurait plus servi à
l'entretien de propriété privée qu'aux
travaux prévus à la jop h ce soir on se
refusait à tout commentaire au conseil
général pourtant commanditaires du
rapport
quant aux anciens dirigeants de
l'association il devrait être
prochainement entendu par la police
judiciaire
un drame dans une maison de retraite de
la somme un incendie qui s'est déclaré
la nuit dernière quatre personnes âgées
ont été surprises dans leur sommeil et
elles ont été asphyxiées le feu serait
d'origine accidentelle le football
maintenant ce soir l'équipe de france
joue pour le compte des qualifications
de la coupe du monde les bleus vous le
savez n'ont pratiquement plus aucun
espoir il faudrait qu'ils gagnent tous
leurs matchs et puis que les autres
équipes qui sont dans le même groupe
réalise des résultats particulier mais
sait-on jamais en tout cas le match
n'est pas terminé il reste encore dix
minutes à jouer
c'est en norvège pour l'instant les
français mènent 1 à 0 un penalty de
papin petit but d'avancé donc avant à
dix minutes de la fin du match
football toujours maradona at il fini
ses caprices
c'est qu'on va le regretter parce que
ses frasques ont bien alimenté tous nos
journaux pendant le mois d'août
hier en tout cas la dives argentine est
revenu en italie et ce matin elle s'est
même rendu à l'entraînement
la star n'a tout de même pas taper dans
le ballon mais elle était présente
francis maroteaux s'est livré à un
marquage sévère du joueur de naples
parce qu'il est enfin revenu diego
armando maradona
n'ayez aucune crainte tout va bien on
est simplement dans le ton locale parce
que dans cette ville sans véritable loi
il y a une vraie foi la foi en dieu
armando maradona
et même si actuellement encore les
joueurs napolitain s'entraîne sans lui
il n'est plus très loin
diego 1 m 68 de l'embonpoint dit on mais
quel bon point pour lui de revenir lui
sur qui on a tant parlé temps écrit
alors pour l'heure diego maradona se
contente de venir voir ses partenaires
mais à la fin de l'entraînement avant de
régler les problèmes avec le président
fairlane haut mais il n'oublie pas de
passer un titre et jour histoire
d'alimenter la polémique permanente apic
les singles et parvint à tâter est pour
l'heure le président de naples est parti
sur son bateau afin de faire patienter
la star dit oh tiens ça change et en
athlétisme les punitions continuent de
pleuvoir pour ben johnson le sprinteur
doper des jeux olympiques de séoul
éliminé des jeux il vient aussi d'être
déchu de son titre de champion du monde
200 m à rome c'était cette course une
course au cours de laquelle il avait
battu le record du monde en 9 secondes
83 centièmes vous en souvenez peut-être
et bien ce record lui aussi est annulé à
deauville au festival du film américain
on attend toujours la grosse artillerie
genre batman ou india jaune indiana
jones qui doit bien en est maintenant au
numéro 40
mais l'événement a été créé aujourd'hui
par un film arrivée en catimini
il s'appelle quand harry rencontre sally
c'est un film qui perpétue la tradition
de la bonne comédie américaine jean
jacques dufour a voulu rencontrer rob
reiner qui est le réalisateur de ce film
sur rob reiner
mais c'est pas non mais je connais
personne n'a vraiment dommage parce
qu'il faut absolument que je le trouve
pour vous le présenter après stand by me
et princess bride
il vient de réussir une merveilleuse
comédie qui a fait craquer tout
deauville mais je suis rob renner
metteur en scène
je suis venu présenter ici mon dernier
film intitulé when harry met sally une
histoire sur le rapport amoureux entre
hommes et femmes
l'extrait que vous allez voir montre sa
vie expliquant à harry jusque-là son ami
que les femmes peuvent prendre leurs
gains attention ce passage pourrait
déprimer les machos trop sûrs d'eux
démonstration immédiate de salies en
tout cas avec son scénario et ses
acteurs rob renner a réussi à ce que le
plaisir des spectateurs ne soit pas de
pain
c'était à enchanter sa heureux moi
j'étais client j'étais ému je me suis
tordu de rire c'est un film subi ils
sont trop mignons du ciel heureux
monsieur renner après la projection
oui je le crois que les gens ont bien
aimé je vous en mets un petit bout aller
oui 15 secondes
voiçi avec toi maintenant vous savez qui
c'est en moi une heure maintenant je
sais qui c'est pas salé brassant film je
le temple c'est autre chose
et oui christian qui est voiturier a du
pain sur les planches pendant le
festival
enfin s'il rate le film de renner il
pourra se consoler en garant la
limousine de milk héros ou de kim
basinger dont on annonce l'arrivée
imminente à deauville voilà il y avait
un tiercé aujourd'hui ce n'était pas à
deauville c'était à longchamp nous
allons voir les résultats
11 14 4 un tiers des faits simples donc
pas de carte et l'heure d'arrivée 2347
front dans l'ordre et dans un ordre
différent ça rapporte 453 francs 50
voilà tout de suite vous avez rendez
vous avec laurent cabrol pour la météo
aussi beau que le temps qu'il prévoit le
dernier journal ce sera henri sannier
très beau lui aussi aux environs de
minuit
et puis demain et bien
télématin comme d'habitude 6h30 je vous
rappelle les rendez vous mady tran pour
l'animation gérard morin pour les
journaux c'était un facteur 38 eur et
puis françois couches lait pour les 4
vérités demain il reçoit le maire de
lyon michel noir excellente soirée sur
antenne 2 à demain 20 heures
je